I have an entire operation
around shopping.
I take it very, very seriously.
I've got loads of items
that I just never even wear.
Beautiful, beautiful quality.
I've had it for over a year.
It hasn't even been
taken off the hanger.
When we look around
the high street and stores
we see lots and lots of stuff,
but the most interesting thing
about consumption
and buying is what's
going on in our minds.
The story of stuff
begins in our imagination
and in our fantasies.
That's the space where we
dream about all the things
that we would really,
really love to have
and what a wonderful life
we would have,
if only we could have this stuff.
I always think, "Yep, this is it.
This is the item.
This is what's going
to make me happy."
What we consume
is an expression of our identity,
because our identity consists
of a number of different facets.
We have an actual self, who we
actually are most of the time,
but then we also have a social self.
We buy products, clothes that express
who we want to be
at any point in time.
I have two moods.
So, I have this mood.
And I also have this mood.
And they're both as vital to me
as the other.
Like, I feel like sometimes clothes
help me take on a character.
Buying something new
makes me feel excited
and like, full of adrenaline.
Marketers are very, very good
at speaking to the
parasympathetic nervous system,
the one that makes
your heart just flutter,
they can't do anything about it.
I buy clothes quite frequently.
I tend to do a lot
of my shopping online
so I have orders come in
at least once or twice a week.
I actually have an order right
now that I'm going to pick up.
It's a new dress and
I'm quite excited to wear it.
Excessive consumption
is actually proven to make us feel
if not bad, it doesn't
make us feel good.
Recent research has shown that
when we have too many things
we are constantly dissatisfied.
Let's say I spend about half
my lunch break looking at clothes,
and then I look a bit
in between work tasks.
And then you add that to
some time when I get home,
and then the actual purchasing -
I would say maybe like
three hours a day
is spent looking at websites,
looking at baskets, returning things,
yeah, it takes up
quite a lot of my time.
Before the 16th, 17th Century
many cultures thought of things
as opposed to the self or the soul,
and what we see in the
modern period is a reversal.
It's a cultural shift that
things start to be seen
as central to our identity.
There's something really interesting
happening actually with consumers.
People are actually beginning
to get fed up with stuff.
We spoke to three generations of
grandmothers, mothers and daughters.
For the grandmother generation,
in that post-war era,
there was a much greater emphasis
placed upon being frugal.
The mother's generation,
they wanted to be modern
and embrace technologies
like the freezer and the microwave.
The daughters rejected a lot of that.
They saw themselves
as being experimental,
buying different ethnic foods,
trying different styles of cooking,
buying organic produce,
ethical products.
What we found was that these
generations of women
were all the same
in wanting to be different,
and the way in which they did that
was through how they shopped
and bought and used stuff.
With the topic around climate change
and the impact the fashion
industry has on the climate,
I am trying to be more
mindful of my shopping.
So I've recently made a rule
to try and make sure that
at least 50% of my wardrobe
comes from vintage stores,
and I really want to get to a point
where I'm more mindful about it
and it's less fast fashion
and less vapid.
We've got so much stuff now, we
don't really know what to do with it.
We spend a lot of time
trying to work out
how to get rid of the stuff
that we've got.
Now, rationally we might say,
"Well maybe we should
stop buying all of this stuff."
But we don't do that.
What we do is retreat
back into our imaginations
and into our fantasies and so
we start the cycle all over again.
I would say yes, I do have a mild
problem when it comes to shopping.
But I like to think that
I could stop if I wanted to.
Oh my god, that's exactly
what an addict says, isn't it?